salut romain ça va toi dans sa pâleur
d'aller un temps qu'est ce qui t'arrive
tu ne sais pas encore été traîné sur
internet à choper une saloperie un
[ __ ] c'est moche c'est déjà arrivé de
sentir votre téléphone vibre et dans
votre poche d'essayer de l'attraper pour
répondre est de constater que 1
il est pas dans votre poche et sur la
table et 2 puis les mêmes pas en train
de vivre est hélas ces vibrations
fantôme c'est votre cerveau qui reçoit
l'information qu'il ya une stimulation
banal contre votre cuisse et qu'il
interprète comme étant une sensation qui
connaît bien et à laquelle il s'attend
votre téléphone qui vibre au point qu'il
arrive à vous bluffez que vous avez
vraiment l'impression de percevoir les
vibrations contre votre chambre
c'est pas vraiment une maladie mais
c'est le signe que les nouvelles
technologies en modifiant les habitudes
de vie elles influencent notre esprit
notre corps et donc notre santé dans un
autre registre à l'arrivée de la
première oui on a pu constater deux
phénomènes
l'augmentation des ventes de télé et
l'augmentation du nombre de tendinites
liés à la manipulation de la manette
d'ailleurs quelques années plus tôt avec
l'arrivée de certains sites web à
caractère récréatif
on avait pu constater deux phénomènes
l'augmentation des ventes des suites ou
et l'augmentation du nombre de
tendinites liés à la manipulation liés à
la manipulation
bon j'avoue là la deuxième partie j'ai
tout inventé dans le futur des nouvelles
maladies vont apparaître
on en parlera un petit peu plus tard les
changements dans nos habitudes de vie
vont aussi augmenter le nombre de cas de
maladies qui existe déjà un peu comme
les casques de réalité virtuelle qui ont
été accusés par de façon assez peu
convaincante pour le coup de transmettre
des herpès oculaire pendant les
démonstrations vous savez quand on se
repasse de tête en tête
en réalité l'avenir risque de nous
réserver d'autres types d'infection plus
sévère avec la mondialisation et les
progrès des transports les distances
réduisent nos déplacements sont plus
faciles et ceux des virus et des
bactéries aussi et eux-mêmes évolue et
s'adapte au monde qui les entoure
certaines bactéries deviennent
résistantes aux antibiotiques à cause
d'une trop grande utilisation de ces
médicaments
les antibiotiques c'est pas automatique
et les virus pareil imite ce qui peut
les rendre plus transmissible plus
virulents et
plus difficile à soigner après ball à
l'organisation mondiale de la santé à
d'ailleurs prévenu qu'il était urgent de
la communauté internationale change sa
façon se préparer aux épidémies futur
c'est trek a toujours une longueur d
avance sur nous il mute
on n'est pas prêt toujours au rayon des
maladies qui existe déjà mais qui
pourrait connaître un boom dans les
années à venir celles liées au
changement climatique la pollution et la
température vont continuer d'augmenter
et avec elle le nombre de maladies
cardiovasculaires et respiratoires mais
aussi d'allergies dans certaines zones
du globe la difficulté de
s'approvisionner en eau potable va
s'aggraver et entraîné une augmentation
du nombre de maladies diarrhéiques et de
problèmes de malnutrition et à cause de
conditions météo qui vont leur être
favorable les moustiques risque d'être
responsable de l'augmentation du nombre
de cas de maladies comme la dengue ou le
paludisme toujours selon l'om en chine
c'est la chine zone ya une maladie
parasitaire causés par des verts qui
pourrait profiter du changement
climatique pour prendre de l'ampleur
ambiance 1 j'anime aussi les mariages et
les anniversaires
il n'y a pas que les maladies qui vont
progresser la médecine aussi dans un
futur sans doute pas si lointain les
nouvelles technologies font partie
intégrante de l'arsenal thérapeutique
des médecins qui permettra de soigner
beaucoup plus efficacement certaines
pathologies mais qui aura aussi ses
effets secondaires
parmi les traitements qui vont continuer
à se développer les implants et les
prothèses ce qui laisse penser au
collectif la santé demain que le métal
isme pourrait apparaît alors le métal
isme c'est pas une société secrète qui
mélange satanisme et musique saturée
le metalist tel qu'il est imaginé c'est
un syndrome qui toucherait les porteurs
d'un plan et de prothèses et qui se
manifesterait par un rejet massif de
l'organisme et une intoxication aux
métaux utilisés comme une sorte de métal
aux massive
ça ça existe déjà dans un mockumentary
le néerlandais floris caïques décrit
même une maladie purement fictive nommé
métallos this may line ya dans cette
pathologie les implants métalliques se
met à grandir et remplace les tissus
humains on est d'accord ça pour le coup
c'est de la science fiction
parmi les traitements très prometteurs
les nanomédicaments font l'objet de
recherche et d'investissements massifs
en gros ça consiste à mettre une
substance disons un médicament dans une
enveloppe de nanomatériaux qui va la
conduire
dans notre organisme directement au
contact de sa cible et l'a libéré là
pour un maximum d'efficacité parle même
de nanorobots qui sont capables de
rechercher les cellules cancéreuses et
de ne libérer le traitement que quand
ils les ont trouvés un désintérêt des
nanomédicaments c'est leur très petite
taille et leur grande précision qui
permet de diminuer les doses et les
effets secondaires mais il ya aussi une
inquiétude concernant la toxicité
éventuelle des nanomatériaux pour notre
organisme et pour l'environnement
une autre inquiétude liée aux
nanotechnologies médical c'est le risque
de dérives et la tentation les utiliser
pour améliorer l'organisme et ses
performances voire d'arriver à une sorte
d'être humains augmenté avec toutes les
conséquences que cela pourrait avoir
ce qui nous amène tout droit à un type
de pathologie qu'on retrouve très
souvent dans les projections sur le
sujet les pathologies psychiatriques
liés aux modifications nos modes de vie
comme celle liée à l'amélioration
artificielle des performances dont on
vient de parler mais aussi celles liées
à la sur utilisation de la réalité
virtuelle qui pourraient être
responsables de certaines formes
spécifiques de psychose une psychose en
psychiatrie est une maladie liée à la
perturbation du rapport à la réalité
ce manifeste notamment par des délires
alors pas des délires genre watros
délire dans des délires genre je ne sais
plus qui est la réalité et ce qui est
une production de nos propres psychisme
voyez un peu le bon maintenant il ya dix
ans disait la même chose des jeux vidéo
attention avant de se quitter parce que
je me sens un peu dans le bade deux
petites précisions
d'abord il ya rien de certifier sur
facture là dedans tout ça c'est juste
des théories des prédictions des
projections des pistes de réflexion
ensuite toutes les évolutions ont leur
part de positif et de négatif
le progrès c'est une médaille car son
revers ça veut pas dire qu'il faut tout
refusé en bloc
en fait c'est un peu comme avec les
médicaments ils ont une certaine
efficacité qui s'accompagnent de risques
d'effets secondaires
l'important c'est de s'assurer que la
balance bénéfices risques penche du bon
côté et d'être vigilants l'été c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve
très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo en
attendant restez cool hein n'ayez pas
peur de l'avenir
on va sûrement changer mon rabat devenir
des monstres ou des robots aller portez
vous bien hausse